They say there are no small parts only small
actors.
But in science there are both and these nanostructures
are the SMALLEST parts and they make a huge
impact.
Hey friends, Trace here, this is DNews.
The prefix Nano- means something really small…
like 10 to the negative 9 small…
Point 000-000-001 centimeters.
Nano has been paired with iPods, materials,
bots, optics, and other super clicky topics,
but though they sound boring, scientists and
engineers are working tirelessly to build
nanostructures because of the physics advantages
of these tiny construction projects!
In February of 2016, the journal Nature Materials
published a paper detailing the smallest lattice
structure ever created by humans.
This is important, because building things
at these tiny scales hack the laws of physics!
Creations like these are called "metamaterials,"
because even though this is made of a type
of carbon, it has properties that are way
different than the normal material.
In this case, the strength-to-density ratio
is six times higher than previously created
materials!
The engineers and scientists think they could
use this new metamaterial for batteries, or
other electrochemical purposes.
Look, I know metamaterials are a bit tough
to grasp, but basically they're specific arrangements
of plastics or metals to take advantage of
a tendency hidden in those elements -- usually
regarding the electromagnetic spectrum.
For example, the reason you can see trees
or Beyonce is because they're made of atoms
that weren't specifically arranged.
Light just bounces off them in all directions.
But, with the right design, a metamaterial
could reroute electromagnetic waves around
an object (called negative refraction) giving
the illusion of invisibility!
It was predicted by Russian physicist Victor
Veselago in the 1960s, and since the founding
of metamaterials as a field, it has been covered
ad nauseum as a possible technological "Harry
Potter" slash "Predator" invisibility cloak.
But that's not nearly the most exciting thing.
Imagine a material that shrinks when stretched,
and grows when squeezed.
A 2006 paper in Nature Materials predicted
just that kind of metamaterial.
If scientists figure out how to make it, this
stuff could reverse expectations in Newtonian
physics!
Cars could be coated in metamaterials that
push back when compressed during crashes…
or bridges and buildings could push back against
the wind!
But that's not all, in Applied Physics Letters,
engineers from Duke found a way to convert
wayward, unused WiFi or satellite signals
into electricity!
I mean, technology is just spewing radio waves
in every direction, so why not grab some of
them?
According to their paper, the metamaterial
is made of "subwavelength particles" and it
can harvest up to 7.3 volts using the slight
vibration that it creates.
Saying "subwavelength" is just further illustrating
how small these things are… that new lattice
I was talking about before?
The struts are only 1 micrometer long… the
whole structure is only 10 micrometers!
It's so small -- that each of those struts
are actually SHORTER than the wavelengths
of some infrared light, and way shorter than
radio!
Okay, so even though the Duke researchers
don't specify what exactly it's made of, they
say in their paper that when radio waves hit
this metamaterial, it resonates, or vibrates.
They harvest that vibration and believe it
could power small electronics pretty easily.
Imagine tiny tech that could harvest power
from satellite signals, radio, or wifi from
your router...
Finally, one more: using 3-D printers, researchers
from Virginia Tech created a macro-scale material
that successfully copied the design of a nanoscale
metamaterial.
They created a cube that has a 400 percent
greater tensile elasticity than normal materials,
with "minimal weight" and "maximum strength!"
Think: flexible armors, lightweight vehicles,
and strong-but-light construction materials
for space!
All because we were playing around with bits
of carbon under a microscope.
To be clear, scientists are still learning
about how all this works.
I mean, the whole field of metamaterials is
pretty new, so there's still a lot to learn.
But, the lead author on that reverse squeeze
material told New Scientist, "We’ve gone
almost as far as we can with high-strength
materials…
The next phase has to be materials that do
completely different things."
So awesome.
If you love watching things get made, you
should watch 'How It's Made!' on Science channel.
I love watching it during lunch actually,
I know that's weird.
And you too can up your lunch game by downloading
Science Go!
On your app store and watch How It's Made
or any other Science Channel show current
or past.
Check the link in the description.
If you want to know more about metamaterials
and plasmonics, check out this video from
a while back explaining more about this crazy
stuff, cause it's crazy.
Does the idea that engineers are creating
things so tiny, you cannot see them with the
naked eye freak you out?
Let us know in the comments and subscribe
for more.
Thanks for watching.